good
good evening
everybody and welcome to tonight's
dialogue entitled rethinking Urban
agriculture my name is Chris lupkin and
I have the pleasure and the privilege of
being the leader of the Strategic
foresight Hub within the Office of the
President at eth Zurich and most
importantly for us this evening I get to
be the host for this
dialogue we are again here in this
Splendid location of the museum for n
kund in Berlin the building which opened
in 1889
was built on the site of an Iron Works
already a regeneration it was bombed
during World War II as you as you can
see it has come back again to life even
more life probably than it had
before the Berlin science week which I
think is a really cool week which I'm
glad to be here provides a forum for
scientists and science-driven
organizations to engage with the public
share insights into current topics
discuss Grand challenges and envision
our future together we at the UT Zurich
are very proud to have been part of
Berlin science week since since its
inaugural Edition in
2017 our dialogue this evening is part
of eth zurich's rethinking living
campaign many of us have the feeling
that we are confronting massive changes
in just about every aspect of Our Lives
climate change biodiversity loss
democracy being disputed Global
pandemics Wars technological disruptions
are all presenting a clear and present
danger to our Global
society and more importantly they also
present us with an opportunity to focus
on focusing on finding solutions to
these Grand challenges to embrace deeper
meaning in our existence and perhaps to
ReDiscover overlooked aspects of Our
Lives rethinking living invites us to
touch the core meaning of our Humanity
our role in the systems of the world
around us and hopefully to foster a
greater sense of purpose so let's get
started with tonight's
conversation I am truly honored to be
here with three incredible individuals
from all sorts of walks of life first we
have Iris Hab Habor she is a senior
scientist and a Project Lead lead of
urban micrology protein project at the
eth center in Singapore there she's
focusing on with her team developing
sustainable resilient solutions for food
production and processing that are
applicable to highly urbanized
environments let's give a welcome to
Iris welcome to
[Applause]
Berlin next to her here in the middle we
have Marcel graph
now Marcel is a designer a filmmaker and
entrepreneur right right Che yeah yeah
of course that's right I'm trying to
figure out the the the antler here with
the and the hunter also yeah yeah yeah
exactly we get to that now his career
has been shaped by creating atmospheres
and emotions as he says and nature is
his deep and profound inspiration to
create unique stories and worlds which
is why he has dedicated himself to the
craft of hunting welcome Marcel thank
you
and finally at the end here on the other
side we have Ana stle who's also a local
if I'm not mistaken true yeah yeah all
right he is a landscape architect and
transformative researcher and her work
focuses on water sensitive design
productive Landscapes and practices of
participation and embodiment and very
very fascinating to see what we're going
to talk about so Anya welcome thank
you so our time together that's both
here in the room and those online will
be about 75 minutes and I will stop at
75 minutes in respect to the next Group
which is coming each of our panelists
are going to start off with a few
minutes explaining what they do
and then uh I have a couple questions to
be asking them and you will also be
invited to pose questions to any and all
of them here and just supp you here in
the room and online online on the
YouTube you're welcome to put into the
chat or in the slido either one on the
website and we'll take as many questions
as we can and I apologize ahead of time
if we don't get to all of them so we'll
do our very our very very best are we
ready oh come on are we ready can do the
zoom thing yeah all right here we go all
right so um how about if we start off
with each one of you describing what you
do and perhaps Iris what is it you
actually do so uh I think uh Chris
already mentioned that I'm actually a
scientist a senior scientist uh that
actually comes from eth Z sustainable
food processing but probably I start
with giving you a broader context of
what we are doing and why we are doing
it so what is our rational behind the
research that we are doing and if you
look at our Agri Food Systems we're
actually facing several challenges so
our current Agri food systems are major
contributors to anthropogenic climate
change change already now we're using
70% of the freshwater that is available
on our planet our agrio system produces
onethird of the global greenhouse gas
emissions and is causing our planet to
transgress Beyond its planetary
boundaries at the same time we waste
oneir of the food that we produce
globally with blind SP blind spots along
the whole value chain and we find
billions of or hundreds of people
thousands of people that have uh uh Mal
uh malnutrition um micronutrient
deficiencies at the same time our food
production would need to increase by 60%
if we want to feed a growing world
population which is estimated to be
around 9.7 billion people in 2050 so our
group is focusing on finding novel raw
materials such as as black soja fly l so
insects but also single cell-based value
chains such as those relying on
microalgae if you don't know what
microalgae are probably a lot of you
know what macro algae are if you look at
uh sushi right you have all these big
nor algae from the sea but we are
looking at very tiny micro algae that
have the size of bacteria and then that
can that are very potent for growing in
urbanized environments and this brings
me to the Singapore context in Singapore
we only have 1% of arable land however
the governance seeks to find Solutions
on how we can increase domestic food
production in Singapore currently
domestic food production is around 10%
and they want to increase this uh share
to 30% by 2030 so we need to find novel
Solutions on how we can produce food
independent of Arab land and also if we
look at the shifts and challenges that
we are facing in 2050 is as estimated
that around 80% of the population will
live in urbanized environments so we
need to find Solutions on how we can
produce food in a more sustainable
resilient way um that is nutritious and
affordable for people and that is
applicable to highly urbanized
environments and currently in Singapore
there's a pressing demand to develop
this so therefore uh we went to
Singapore to develop these solutions for
urban food production and processing now
just really quick but are these the
singles of the algae is protein or is it
carbohydrates or what that what is it
actually it's everything so a lot of
people uh now our times they focus on
protein but we think of a more holistic
way of providing nutritious food and
actually inside the microalgae depending
on the species that you use you can find
up to 70% of protein but we also have
very uh other very nutritious nutrients
like omega-3 fatty acids uh vitamins
there are also carbohydrates
uh some species possess uh vitamin B12
uh an antioxidants so they're very
versatile in their composition okay cool
thank you Marcel I think your world is a
little different a little bit yeah yeah
so tell us about your world yeah you
already introduced me but uh I think the
reason why I'm here uh this evening is
because I go hunting and I have my own
hunting School in Berlin and I teach
people to go hunt to live with nature
and um yeah to learn more about nature
and yeah that that's my passion that's
my lifestyle and uh I try to to gave my
philosophy to other people to show them
to live or to be one with nature uh yeah
what happens out there and um to see the
conflicts um um yeah to to produce your
own food because hunting is not like you
go out and shoot an animal it's much
more it's the smallest part um to to
pull the trigger that's uh absolutely
and so yeah I try to give my philosophy
and all um the stuff behind um hunting
and the stories um to other people and
um yeah so so let me ask you a question
I found you we found you because you
were officially at one point one of the
Berlin I call it pig hunters yes yes so
very I don't know how many people knew
that the city of Berlin in an urban
environment also has
official pig hunters normally it's a
secret uh we don't have hunters in in
the city in the city area yeah but what
I am one of them and um somebody of you
maybe you know we have a big problem
with uh White B in Berlin in in and
around Berlin and uh you have to
moderate the conflict um to to teach
people what can you do to protect your
garden your house um when they are on
the playground when they on the highway
what do you have to do and sometimes yes
of course we have to uh take them away
so um this is very very interesting to
see um when you live in a big city like
Berlin and the wildness is next to you
it's is your neighbor wild boes or
raccoons or uh rud deers um they live
next to us but when they live next to us
we also have conf PL because you know
they look so sweet and so pretty but
when they destroy your garden you don't
want them anymore in your garden
so what we have to do next so uh
sometimes there we have yeah we have a a
very very big population of White boss
in and around Berlin and that's the
reason why we have to hunt them and yeah
to moderate it thank you we going to
come back with a couple other question
questions but now I want to come to Ana
who builds Gardens in the city Ian this
is one of the things you've been doing
that he was just talking about with the
the schwine and the deers will come tell
us a little bit more about what you do
and why yeah um actually you said it I'm
a landscape architect um and I'm
researcher too so at the moment I'm
working at the Technical University and
we do that what we talk about here today
we do um take care about the transfer of
research results but but um looking to
my heart in my Daily Business um it's
actually about creating Landscapes
within the urban shape so I made Gardens
but at the moment um we do research
about aquaponic and hydroponic farming
and building integrated ways of um
producing food and um we do that because
actually I'm loving the landscape and I
I I feel that relationship to nature but
I think we live in a phase where nature
is hardly changing and what we have to
learn is that um the urban agriculture
or the new nature is looking different
it's made by plastic it's fish and
farming within the city we use the
facades and the roofs of the city itself
it's like a new picture we need to
discover what we have and um what I did
in the last years actually it was a
project we went quite deeply through
that discussion about aquaponic and
hydroponic farming and we used um
recycled Wastewater within the city
center so we run a living lab near to
POA plots and there it's possible to
clean up gray water that's the water
what is coming from the um bath tube
it's all the water which which is not
going to the toilet and when you are
separate that two flows um you can
recycle that water in one day that it's
nearly that has nearly drinking water
quality and um within that buildings in
the 80s I think um they started to reuse
it within the building and we said okay
if it's nearly drinking water quality
why we don't farm with it and so we
started in 2016 there um to no it was
2013 sorry to um show that it's possible
to use that surface water it's recycled
gray water for producing fish and um
vegetables in a greenhouse um in a small
yard and we made a lot of design
research about um which buildings could
cover such an infrastructure as a new
infrastructure for the city it's a
living system it's not a pipe it's
something you can touch something you
can see you grow food within and you can
do that on the roofs in the facade so
actually what is
really um how to say that driving me to
do that research is a deep um I really
believe that we have to discover the
city and its resources for creating new
Gardens and new Natures which look not
that romantical like the ones we have
it's not really landscape it's urbanized
MH pattern but within that urbanized
pattern we find um we are able to see
our own resources which we can recycle
and it's not just waste it's water it's
energy it's actually the flow we call it
the um
food food water energy Nexus which is
really really important looking to that
urbanized land landcapes you were
talking about we are far away from
having some actually landscapes for
urban Agriculture and coming back to my
garden my heart as a gardener um it's a
lot about biodiversity I think we have
to learn to accept Wilderness um within
cities it's not about all about food
farming it's the same what we need is
place for other species to be we really
have to learn that we are not the only
ones so um um there were actors Nature
has different actors they are right
beside us and this um shift and
understanding and creating nature is
something with what's really driving me
so really there you're talking about
closing some of the loops which we talk
about the circular economy or ecological
Cycles trying to close that Loop in a
holistic way yeah yeah and so you're
saying being able to live next to actors
I mean Marcel in a way this is what you
you're also yes wanting to share is how
you live with these other actors so I
want to ask you Marcel what's the
biggest surprise when
you're W when people come with you to
learn what's the biggest thing that
surprises those who are learning with
you about nature and about
hunting um I would say the biggest
surprise is um they learn to see they
see much more when they go outside in
nature to the woods with me um they will
see some things you you never saw before
and I would say
hunting is teaching you to see what
happens out there because you spend so
much time you it's like meditating
you're sitting there for hours and you
have so much time to look around and you
will understand all the
um yeah the the ecosystem much better
because you sitting there and you're
waiting and you have so much time to
look around and yeah I would say um the
biggest surprise for them is to see so
many different things how um animals
different animals act together they they
live together and yeah they spent their
time of course together I I had a very
nice picture um I saw in the city there
were white BS and recs in one big group
it was two white BS and the raccoons and
they moving around the street and it was
so funny because it's like a movie you
know so they they they live and yeah
maybe also they work together could be a
new move it could be a new movie titled
the bors of Berlin yeah yeah yeah a
double meaning there we don't think of
Berlin is a boring
Place get it bad bad bad joke in English
sorry but I'm I I'm going to ask you the
same question with those you've been
working with with your students and your
community members
what have you observed has been their
biggest surprise when they learn about
these closing those Loops of the other
species um so the maybe well there I
mean the biggest surprise was we started
as um we started with research funding
and this research funding um was about
multifunctional infrastructures was
really technology so there was not
really a link to nature but we created
that link when we said we want to do
aquaponic and hydroponic farming and we
want to um do that to um develop that
Loop so we had um to show that there
some people would accept such a
technology because it's Wastewater and
we are coming from industrial or we have
still I think industrial mindsets where
we think this is something which goes
far away and we will never come back so
um we decided actually to do um quite
transparent work and um opened up that
greenhouse and from the first day we
made a strawberry
celebration there were more than 300
people coming I think we had talking
about animals we had a little star our
fishes We call we were talking about
that aquaponic um farming where you have
the fishes as little stars um but after
that first day until today and it's I
think more than 11 years now we have so
many visitors just coming to see that
that technology just coming to um get in
touch with that water see that it's
possible to um create some food there
and there was for me the most the
greatest thing within the whole research
I thought we do technology but what we
did actually was communication and we
discovered that doing the job and um
because of that today we develop smaller
structures which actually can move to
the city because this technology is
really a technology which teaches us
another relationship to nature and I
think this is the most important part
because um it's it's more than food it's
like you you are talking about the
animals it's going there um
understanding what you are doing
understanding that once when you um that
the water is coming from actually the
building that you can do something there
within the greenhouse the
kids for the kids we we are we have a
lot of um young people coming from
kindergartens and schools and they look
at the the Technologies and and for them
it's normal and you really see that you
can change the mindset that it's um that
you can learn um creating and designing
that systems and and those processes I
think are the really really important
that was the biggest surprise for me
that's great that's great because in
many ways there's no such thing as waste
it's just another type of resource this
is what you're helping them these
individuals see that is just a resource
we have to do something with yeah but
now you're both are speaking of a world
which is quite different than the world
you live in in the sense of gardens wild
bores all around and having to manage
the forest
beasts Singapore is a very dense City
and it's known as a Garden City so it's
not it's not
green but no I don't think many citizens
have a garden or can throw tomatoes out
in the garden someplace
so H how do you when you hear that so
but you grow up over here so but how do
you see this when with your work and how
is Singapore relevant to say Berlin and
what you're doing yeah yeah so I would
partially disagree actually to what you
were saying before like that I'm very
different from what the two of them are
doing actually because part of our
research is also looking on how can we
integrate those systems that we we are
developing uh into living areas in
Singapore because we don't just want to
produce or go somewhere to Malaysia or
Indonesia produce there and ship
everything uh to Singapore right this is
not the idea we want to produce there
and we need to find centralized uh
Solutions probably with consumers um I
was always dreaming of people have their
3D printer and they have their algae at
home right and then they can just uh do
uh tailor the printing of broccoli us
using microe probably sometimes in the
future and then I think also what what
we are also trying to emphasize is that
um I mean a big topic is around meat
consumption and that we should reduce
meat consumption and uh Masa approach is
actually also what we are promoting
right saying having a kind of meaningful
uh consumption of meat and really
thinking of where the meat comes from
and having the connection and then
eating meat yes but yeah thinking about
it and having it I don't know once a
week once every twice week because uh
every second week because it's part of
our culture and it should be part of our
nutrition but just uh yeah question it
and um have the have the sense uh behind
it somehow and then of course Singapore
is completely different from um from
Berlin also meaning that uh we see a lot
that people are very disconnected from
food and food production they don't know
where their food comes from and this is
then creating some issue I mean we need
to import 90% of the food in Singapore
right but a third still gets lost cost
and cheap is food is also very cheap in
Singapore so um yeah and we realize a
lot that people have a big disconnection
from from food production therefore if
we can Implement micro AIO or any kind
of other solution uh a lot of people
also do vertical farming as a solution
we have vertical shrimp Farms actually
uh since last year in Singapore start up
doing that if you can create some kind
of connection to food and food
production and then a more meaningful or
reasonable
um way of dealing with food so I'm
really intrigued by this all three of
you have spoken of the need for a better
connection to Nature and n and algae is
nature nature is a technology nature is
what you just said there with the garden
and and I'm intrigued by it's unexpected
for me that this all of you would say
this is what we need when we're
rethinking Urban agriculture is to get
more
connected comment what do you you
think so yeah I mean like I commented
before right uh I feel probably it's
just a feeling for me but uh if people
don't know where their food comes from
we see it a lot with meat people
actually don't want to see where pigs
are produced so we get a lot of comments
uh we are producing alternative meat
analoges and then people uh claim
they're ultr processed but actually it's
not Ultra process it's just a a
misunderstanding actually of the process
that is happening and also with food
processing we can get nutrients that
otherwise we couldn't get um we we have
bread for instance that comes from
processing
so it's interesting how many of you ask
where your food comes from how of you
know where all your food comes from how
many how many of you know okay the
grocery store right okay I get that
right but it's a really it's an
intriguing it's an intriguing point
which again this is unexpected so but I
want I want to change the Tex a little
bit I want to think when we think the
the theme
rethinking
Urban agriculture when we rethink say
we're looking forward say 20 years when
we're rethinking what does this in your
mind or your hearts what does this evoke
this rethinking an what what would what
does it mean for you um for me it's it's
better now with a mic yeah yeah cuz your
hair was making a
funny um I think the the reth thinking
is we we have different um sources or
other sources we have to deal with our
own waste we have to discover waste we
have to discover new food I think and
um we have to to um forget that we have
Urban Landscapes and Landscapes and
agriculture I think um we have to think
that all together and more systematic
and this approach brings us actually I
think to a rethinking of urban
Agriculture and to to scale that I think
or if you don't want to fail in scaling
for that we need the connection MH to
not make the um the old mistakes we made
mhm I think this is the rethinking for
me the most important part and the other
um quite important part is the non-human
actors to accept that there are actors
um beside us which um maybe are our food
or live within the city shape or they
are just
um they live in parts of the world which
are completely which are wild and
Wilderness we need because we know that
we need that places so and this for me
this is a new like a bit stepping away
from nature and um creating something
new and that the same time um it's more
respect I think to all those processes
okay okay great thanks so marel what
about you when you say rethinking Urban
agriculture what does that evoke for you
um yeah I think uh hunting uh cannot
constitute uh Revolution for the uh for
the food problem in our society but uh
you can get a better awareness for food
and um to produce your own meat uh or
your own food like our
grandparents um yeah so I think we have
to find out how much Wilderness we want
in our um urban areas because for me
it's super easy I know a lot of I would
say a lot of our nature to be with
nature to live with um wild animals but
I would say the most people in our
society um forgotten how
to um interact with our nature and yeah
we have a big problem with white balls
in and around Berlin they are not so
dangerous when you know how to um uh how
interact with them to interact with them
but yeah we have a new player in our
habitat it's uh a wolf so for me it's
super nice it's a beautiful animal but
you have to decide how cool it how cool
you are with when you go to the woods
with your dog and a wolf is next to you
for me it's easy but you have to decide
what is it a problem for you you know
what to do
and um this is the question we have to
ask I think and um yeah it uh doesn't
will take time so long time that the
wolf comes to Berlin because it's super
easy to get food here because the wild
BS and the rudar are not so you know
they are not so shy like in the
wilderness yeah so when they find it out
where where I lived in California we we
had lots of um missing
cats because we we had we had wolves and
and so that was so basically wolf food
yeah rethinking Urban agriculture for
you what does that mean yeah so I think
I got um a different understanding of
urban agriculture when I moved to
Singapore so before I lived actually
seven years in Zurich which we already
considered the biggest city of
Switzerland and then you move to
Singapore slight different
so because yeah I mean there's only 1%
of Arab land but then if you travel
around Asia I mean I've also been to so
now uh taipe these are mega cities and
then you need to have completely
different concepts of food production
and also think about how can we
integrate it the food production with
people probably directly next to their
buildings but another topic that Ana was
also um emphasizing is the food waste so
actually in Singapore we import 90% what
do we do with the waste and there are no
centralized decentralized system somehow
on how we are treating the waste but we
will be generating it uh and C currently
there's uh I think a lot of gas
production uh with the waste we are
working also with black soja fly La uh
as organic waste treatment technology
where we could be using the protein from
The Black soja Fly L for more
sustainable uh feed it could also be
food but currently there's no food
application in in case there are very
brave people in here um feel free to
also uh try these crawling La ones um I
did uh yeah so we have a completely
different understanding then of urban
agriculture uh but of course we need to
combine it with more sustainable
practices also of traditional
agriculture I think which we shouldn't
neglect so it cannot only be novel
resources novel approaches such as
vertical farming because they cost a lot
of energy still yeah any go ahead yes I
want to um um I think another rethinking
another part um quite important part is
the climate change we have to think that
together with all the challenges we have
just looking to climate change for
instance in Berlin I mean as a local
when we have the strong way folds in
Berlin all the fishes in the rivers are
dying because our um Wastewater
infrastructure system is collapsing and
this is not something easy and um to
face all that Wicked problems together
and to develop Integrated Solutions I
think this is rethinking Urban
agriculture Urban agriculture is or
rethinking it is climate adaption and
climate change we have to think about
new practices maybe some flooded I don't
know Fields some um something in the
facades or on the roofs or different
food and um to understand that that we
are actually
facing a complex crisis and developing
solutions for that this is I think
reinking Urban agriculture a really
great point is because we have a new
context we're all walking into right
sometimes sleepwalking but the reality
is we are looking at a a two to four
degree change in in the temperature
depending on where you are in Europe I
me in Switzerland we're going to have
experienced 4.2 degrees when the rest of
the world is at 1.5 or so and this has
massive impacts on the contextual
parameters to rethink as you just said
before and you're talking about the
systems looking at this holistic systems
we've been trying to think of this
integration and as that changes I think
that's a really really really
interesting point i' like to ask this uh
for in the room or online if anyone has
a question they'd like to ask at this
point I see one hand there's one online
that's two when we get to 10 then I then
we're going to go for we got three okay
we're gonna got one more question and
I'm going to come come to you all okay
um
Anna you mentioned uh also when we were
talking ahead of time about some of the
work on the roof water farming
strategies and where that might go and
your hope with bringing folks in that
they're going to see these kind of
opportunities do you see other places in
the world where this is happening
already do you know of any other places
where this is a more common practice or
is this something you're you're trying
to hoping to
to to spread well
um I'm I I started laughing because um
burlin is not really a modern city so
everywhere in the world I think this is
really happening and um in Berlin the
roof water farming practices we
um we develop are some but there is a
lot missing but I think if you look to
some big cities which are able to to um
adapt to climate change for instance and
they start to um use rainwater and to
understand that maybe
a um children's playground can be
flooded and that you can um live with
that and um I think those cities or
Singapore is a good um example for
farming but um to really understand what
a city itself can do to adapt to all
that questions I think you have to
integrate all that other water issu
um like rainwater for instance so this
is what I'm meaning um with the climate
change
we start to discuss blue green
infrastructure building integrated
farming and I think we are on the point
where we start to understand that we
develop new
integrated um Technologies and then we
that we develop new systems for the
Urban Planet actually and Berlin is not
on the um not Berlin is not really doing
a lot with it with all that not yet not
yet maybe hopefully tomorrow but at the
moment I think it's we live in a Time
political wise it's going it's a wall
back but um and so um to answer your
questions yes there are a lot of other
places Okay cool so questions one two
three now we have enough questions to
start going okay um m microphone if we
can go ahead and start with the up here
on the front left and I have a couple in
slid if you're online you're welcome to
put them into the slid or the YouTube
please go ahead and do those and then
I'll I'll scrape them here go ahead and
if you can stand up as you're doing
thank you that helps with that and
please make sure it's a question and not
a a long statement yeah thanks so much
for the discussion uh so I was just like
directly like on the last statement what
you were saying like um so maybe like
Bellin wants to be climbed n city by
2045 and um do you see this can be
reachable like with maybe integrating
more like G green blue infrastructures
but like what is there the drive also
for the government because I'm working
for the government and it's not easy to
implement uh the stuff which is like the
technology is there but uh it's not the
implementation takes so long and what
how we can accelerate the process
great question thank
you directly answer you can go for it
right yeah
um last month I went to a conference
about blue green infrastructure and that
um there was a keynote about um there
were a lot of pictures of Stockholm for
instance where it's already possible to
construct blue green infrastructures to
bring the rainwater to the trees and not
to the pipes and um the whole day um was
a discussion about um how to renew all
that streets and in Berlin we Face the
problem that the we have those huge
pressure of creating um places to live
we have all that construction sites and
sometimes I have the feeling nothing is
going on so I think if we would learn um
how to integrate all the people for
instance to to change a street it's
maybe you need an engineer but if you
ask a lot of other people to help to
develop a new INF structure the
neighbors the kids then I think we can
become then it will be easier but this
um to go this is actually the the the
bigger picture of participation and a
bigger picture of knowledge transfair
and it's a it's stepping out of the idea
that we need a lot of experts to do that
I'm really sure that we have the
solutions what we have to learn is to
integrate a lot of people into that
process
to get more faster because it's not that
um it's easy we know how it goes we know
we see the trees dying we know that the
rain is rain water is falling down and
we just have to bring it to the trees we
see the Farms we have two aquaponic
farms in Berlin and we know the
technology so um the berina Vasa I don't
know what's that in English they say
Berlin will become a sponge City but we
need a huge amount of money I don't
believe that we need people to work on
this and we need to find that people to
do that and I think this is the part we
have to learn it's not engineering it's
taking care about the urban shape and
stepping into that huge transformation
we have to do to unlock the public
potential there's also some legal Parts
too like in Hong I Liv in Hong Kong you
always every toilet was flushed with sea
water not with fresh water like why
flush your toilet with drinking water
it's kind of stupid actually but but you
have to have the pipes to do that and
that's part of it's a legal there's also
legal requirements for that so I have a
question here online which is really
quite intriguing for me for you is that
does Co influence how did how did Co how
did Co influence all of your thinking
and all of your
work did Co have any impact on your
research and your thinking about this or
I mean yeah this is a one of the reasons
that Singapore is really putting so much
pressure on increasing domestic food
production okay because they were facing
so many supply chain disruptions and if
you import 90% of your food um you're
heavy heavily riant on all these
Imports and then uh when Co happens of
course um Singapore was heavily impacted
by that so they wanted to increase uh or
decided to increase domestic food
production so it's really a national
critical yeah I mean yeah they see like
like uh how dependent they are and they
want to reduce that yeah it's very
interesting I often wonder how long
we'll be able to import tomatoes from
drought stricken places like uh like
Spain because basically you're exporting
water and how does that makes sense you
know it's like anyway so Marcel what
about for you when how did Co impact
your yes there was a very big impact
because uh so many people had so much
time and um also yeah the they so your
business boomed my business boomed yes
of course um yeah I'm not I'm not
kidding because uh the the people want a
connection back to to Nature and so my
business was
absolutely super fine and yeah the the
people want the connection Back To
Nature to um produce uh their own meat
their own uh food and um yes it was a I
would say a very positive impact in my
business so before I come you Ona you
have an antler in front of you yeah and
tell us why you brought that and because
it's about as old as coid in the sense
isn't it or no yeah I bring this uh
antler with me um to show you how long
does it take a red deer um is ready um
to harvest uh this one is 10 years old
now he's still alive uh a Red Deer uh
lose his andler every year and it takes
three until 5 months to build it new so
uh for for me as a
hunter it's very important to look what
happens out there to find out uh which
rud deer is ready to harvest which is
good for the population and which one we
can uh take out for producing like
sausage meat uh stuff like this yeah and
it's it's a long time and it's very
heavy and uh it shows you uh how
fascinating um the nature nature is so
yeah that was the reason why I bring you
this so they these they they knock these
off and they make a new one every year
yeah yeah is yeah that's crazy it's a
lot of work it's a lot of a lot of
calcium where do they get the calcium to
do this or I don't know this is anyway
yeah with the nutrient okay I what you
for Co and I just want to add something
um my kids we saw a a show about that
thing here and um maybe you know that
better than me when it's growing it it's
covered by some um for fuzz until the
last moment before it Felts down it's
cover it do not get um hurt it's
incredible what nature is creating I
mean true sorry go ahead you want to
answer or no no you're absolutely right
Co tell Anya for you co how did it how
did this is a question about it's kind
of curious yeah Co um actually for me
it's more a private um thing I realized
I have two children so I try to work and
to stay at home and um they were four I
think four and five years old with in
that time but um professional wise we we
did actually um a lot of international
teaching so we had the rof water F
Publications we had a Muk online and we
started to give SE seminars and to do
the
bring the knowledge to um to an
international scale and there was really
um a good work there was um I think a
point where you could talk to everybody
somewhere within that um on that planet
and we all felt um that problem and
everybody stayed at home and had the
feeling I have to do something I have to
change something we have actually a
crisis and that for me was the most
important part because you could feel
that we are able to react that we are
able to manage crisis that we are able
to change and um I thought this will
stay but and looking to that um on I
think today we we are back to normality
yeah whatever normal is or we'll just
say we've kind of Forgotten our our
Collective potential there are about a
few more other questions here in the
back there go ahead and then and then
we'll come up and then this way up here
yeah go ahead yeah thank you for the
banel uh I just have a question because
I work as an ESG manager for a real real
estate company and uh we're doing so
many manage measures regarding uh
sustainability and one topic is the
biodiversity but the problem is we don't
really have an actual tangable uh return
on investment so what could be the
return return on investment especially
that we're not focusing into the food
production but more or less the
supporting species Within specific areas
so what do you think of
that go ahead if you want I think I
think the um it's a actually it's it's
Health you bring to the people which
live there this is actually what will
happen and
um it's it's um from I think it's taking
care about the place and creating
um creating places where you actually
feel that it's in summer not hot that
you have the animals around you it's
creating different places I think this
is the most important
thing any other comments from
anyone okay we're gonna keep going
here's another question right here the
plaid shirt and then we're going to come
right no behind next to the camera there
we go thank you
um funny question maybe um we have
learned today that
um meeting wolves in in the woods is is
a part of the rethinking Urban
agriculture um as I do not feel so far
so at ease with meeting wolves I would
like um to know whether you could give a
very quick introduction what to do in
this
case I go for hunting um
mushrooms and um all of a sudden I have
such
encounter I need to say it's very good
because there also more and more wolves
in Switzerland so if you go hiking you
should be aware that okay this is sounds
like this is a very critical skill which
we need to transfer right now so
normally uh they are super shy and they
will uh move away when they hear you so
when you're very loud when you search
for M mushrooms it's I would say uh the
best thing um yeah and don't uh don't
come too close uh it's a it's a wild
animal it's not like a dog they maybe
look sweet and they look very
fascinating um and they're very close
but try to give give them space and
don't don't uh push them in in a
Direction go back be a little bit loud
that the wolf can hear you and then you
will not have a problem so normally it's
super easy but um yeah a lot of
people um yeah forgot how to live with
animals I mean it's super easy for you
to say I'm sure for the rest of us if we
would see a wolf maybe we maybe you back
just back you look at in the eye and you
back up or you just turn around and run
or what no you you you be very
very I would say slow in your movements
okay so don't be uh nervous or something
like
that nervous yeah of course it sounds so
easy but uh that's that's the point um
that's the point how to live with
animals with white animals in in Germany
or in Europe it's much easier than in
Asia or in Africa you have uh much more
dangerous animals next to your door uh
than a wolf it's it's so funny yeah
okay funny is not necessarily the word I
think I would use with that one but okay
that's a that's a really good point you
always say when you see Bears I know
when you go hik in in the Rocky you're
supposed to be very loud you carry a
bell and you talk you know loudly yeah
so for those who like to walk quietly
through a forest it's sort of the
opposite and this is intriguing there's
a question right here and then I have
another one online then we're going to
swing around to the other side yeah
thank you um I see Urban agriculture as
a potential climate solution and for me
as a journal I look for certain factors
uh when it when it comes to climate
Solutions first feasibility two
scalability three
sustainability and four conserv ability
so what the fourth one conserve
conservation point of view conserva
ility so if you were to give scores on
your respective Fields you know um like
in Singapore or uh in Berlin or hunting
what would be your scores of all these
four
factors I'm writing up the scorecard
right here here are the factors all
right the first one like all together or
like a like a general
score yeah so feasibility scalability
sustainability conserv ability that's
relationship with nature I'm assuming
yeah it's relationship with nature
feasibility mite of this then
scalability come yeah
thentic sustainable then conserv ability
what's its relationship to Nature and
and species and yeah that correct okay
yeah I can go for that so usually what
we encounter is that uh most people say
alternative protein based on Precision
fermentation microalgae is more
sustainable it's it's a super
sustainable solution always if you hear
that you should be CR I because
currently all these Solutions are not
more sustainable in terms of in terms of
um energy consumption for instance if
you compare it to Soy or even chicken
because these are highly optimized
systems over years MH so but we are not
anymore in basic research uh level so if
we look at the technology Readiness
level we are somehow so we are Beyond
basic research there is upscale going on
and if if we have more upscaling more
economy of scale as we always say we can
also decrease uh the cost and improve
the sustainability Factor but then for
the microalgae or other um cultured
cultured meat for instance you always
need to look at the energy consumption
and we need to find more sustainable
energy actually for fueling also all
that because then if you use still
traditional energy sources it is still
questionable right whether the are
really more Sustainable Solutions so
they're not yet probably uh there to be
implemented in the next year or the next
two years but probably in 10 years 15
years but they're not yet basic research
anymore as as understand you're an The
Innovation curve you're still we're
still on the on the upper part right
we're not we're not as you said you're
not quite to the scaling part yet and
yeah you're still the system still needs
to evolve around you yeah so what we
actually look at is usually the
technology Readiness level yeah so scale
that is developed by NASA or um where we
look at is it basic research is it close
to application is it
industrialize and usually before
industrialization you have some kind of
dip that we call the valy of death that
a lot of Technologies get lost so in
Singapore we are working more towards
the application towards
industrialization that we don't have
this tip we are working on the right
side of of this dip actually and there
are companies in Israel that are
upscaling micro Al production so
Technologies are are there we just need
to do it at scale I think so I'm not
sure if this was addressed to all
three mostly mostly the IRS right just
two okay
so yeah yeah sustainability I did and
conserv ability is relationship to
conservation so to to Nature
conservation in
general I mean we are in
Singapore okay enough there we go all
right so so I mean probably previously
there was was a lot of biodiversity but
in theory what we are developing are
solutions that are independent of arabel
land what we could be using is already
existing stainless steel tanks that you
for instance use for beer brewing and
then then we go to the underground to
void spaces that are currently not used
they're just empty so that would be our
idea and then you can use the arable
land for uh reforestation or
for yeah getting biodiversity in again
cool did you want the others to answer
this or are you happy with
the okay you're satisfied at the moment
do either of you want to go for this one
as well the first one feasibility um so
but we are there it's constructable um
you actually there in Berlin there are
two buildings um and last year they have
this this gray water treatment within
the building and um place left for the
farm
coming um this technology the roof water
Farm Technology um needs someone working
with it so it doesn't make any sense to
produce fish or herbs where when you um
if you don't have anybody using that
things so talking about
scalability um we discovered that it's a
quite diver technology so it's possible
to run a restaurant with aquaponic
farming a small restaurant at the same
time you can run a social housing or
there was the actually um the next step
we will do you bring it to a school
building and teach um the children that
questions you can teach with that
technology so it's not scalable until
there it's bringing diversity and for me
this is the main shift and um um what
else feasibility scalability
sustainability sustainability using
waste water or service water for farming
makes completely sense and um if you for
instance um we made a we made Network
Maps imagining that you will bring that
Farms to the places where the city is
producing waste heat up there um so
every big um treatment plant can have a
farm so and this is bringing more and
more sustainability and you learn to
cross the loop we have a small farm at
um a beach site here in Berlin at GL Dr
Park there you can play beach volleyball
then you go shower ring and then the you
shower water that's going through the
vertical Farm you can see your salad
growing and then you can um earn your
salad go to the restaurant and eat the
burger and then you have closed the loop
and so I think this is 100
points and the um conservation part um
at our living Lab at P plat we combine
the technology with an urban swamp so we
bring parts of the gray water into um
Wetland to cool down the city and um
combining that practices with blue green
infrastructure for rainwater for
instance or gray water or that swamps
it's bringing diversity and it's
incredibly beautiful to walk through the
wetlands in the middle of the city
center yeah that's great thank you sorry
in German we say iob stin but I don't
know what's it in
English oh show yeah of course maybe I
can give you a very simple example uh
out of my point of view um uh it's
winter it's cold outside you have a
fireplace at home of course you need
wood yeah you have to go out uh in the
forest to cut down a tree to bring it
home chop it into pieces and then you
have to wait two years until you can
burn it so to cut a long story short
it's a lot of work so when it's winter
now you're sitting on the sofa and you
are freezing and you have a look to your
fireplace and the wood you will remember
how much work it was to bring the wood
to your place and I promise you will go
upstairs put a polo uh um a sweater on
and yeah for me it's the point I don't
have to eat meat every day or avocado
from uh everywhere
it's sometimes it's much more simple um
to find a solution and to think about
how we act in our society so yeah it's a
great answer thank you for that may I
ask something you you ever thought about
tiny Forest within the city par you ever
thought about tiny forests so we have
that small you know tiny any fors no so
it's I'm okay maybe we talk about that
we'll go that afterwards more questions
we have a couple more questions here we
have one go ahead this gentleman right
here and then we're going to go around
okay we'll get you then we're gonna go
on this side go ahead hi um I'm very
interested in aquaponics so um first a
question for ana um you talked about all
these fascinating facilities where can I
find them maybe there is a website and
how how can I visit them
um the second I guess is a little bit
more you get one question one question
oh okay um one question about aquaponic
what are the uh challenges or what are
the advantages that we can see maybe
also in Singapore or in Berlin okay
thanks a lot thank you sorry I'm a mean
guy I know terrible and we're get the
check shirt next and we're run here
aquaponics or any any thoughts go
ahead so in Berlin we have I think two
big aquaponic Farms it's efficient City
farming in templehof and it's the um
stat farm
and where is it if cnick I think yeah M
I think so yeah so both of them do um
aquaponic farming on an industrial scale
and both of them I think the um
efficient City farming they bring it to
supermarkets and um St Farm is running a
small shop so and there are a lot of
aquaponic Farms world white which
struggle because they become too big so
I think the most important part in
aquaponic farming is that you understand
who needs the product why you do that
and what kind of water you use we are
the only ones um working with service
water and you are working with animals
and you need actually um that
relationship is it's it's not just
abstract food production it's aquaponic
farming for someone and I think this is
the most important part and for sure
it's all about that it's the same with
um the vertical Farms you have to think
about the energy you use if you run it
in summer and winter or if you close it
in winter and that's you have to think
it as a loop and um in Berlin there we
have that farms and you can come to the
roof water Farm you can we can show you
the technology there are a lot of
aquaponic Farms growing at the moment
but
um they have to be diverse I think
that's the most important part great
thank you very good any comment on
Singapore if you keep going um yeah I
think uh s Singapore now Taps more and
more into doing that uh because they
want to be independent also in their
fish supply so they have different
strategies there and they also do their
aquaponics what we look more at is
actually the feet that are provided to
the fish which is again black soldja fly
La that we are trying to rare on organic
waste that you find around uh in
Singapore so having kind of uh food
waste or organic waste treatment
technology and then using these La as
more sustainable feed for the for the
fish in the aquaponics H interesting but
I'm not an expert in that unfortunately
very interesting I didn't know that yeah
oh thank you yes sir thanks for the
second chance knowing that oh wait a
minute you already had one you put your
hand up again you sneaky guy you no not
at
all um a question to ana um as as you
just said that Berlin is um a little
bit not in advance with um proceeding um
could you give us just your three best
off examples of other cities when when
we um want to look it up tonight after
after the session here um to get more um
inspiration in in which directions to
think three I think the it's not about
aquaponic farming but it's about using
um the roofs and the facades and the
buildings and and bringing it to
actually to adapt it to climate change
is Paris just look what um the ma major
is doing at the moment and how big the
farms grow and what they areow
um I think Stockholm is developing quite
well in case of how can we reconstruct
the city and develop um blue green
infrastructure I'm I'm not sure if they
have farming
and actually Singapore is always our um
example for thinking Urban agriculture
on the bigger scale
and yeah just I think if you do there
are a lot of small farms growing at the
moment and um I said that about Berlin
because I was born here and I saw what
the how the city developed in the last
years and
um yeah that's why I said we are not the
best ones but I would love that we could
be like Paris in case of Regulation
understanding what the buildings are
Stockholm I think is quite intelligent
and redesigning
infrastructure and Singapore is
rethinking Urban agriculture yeah that's
great great examples you know it's quite
interesting because about 10 or 15 years
ago Singapore decided to try to capture
every single drop of rain which fell on
the nation and so they really started
thinking how can we do this as part of
the scheme for rethinking their Urban
water system including what they call
new water which was the first time they
started reusing water for human or
secondary consumption so it's actually
this rethinking the systems which we
have around us and I think this quite
quite interesting as assets there's a
question right
here Luna you had a question and then
we're gonna go walk our way back hi um
my question is maybe more technological
if you have tried or experience with aop
poning
aeroponics any no no okay we have um we
at the roof water Farm living lab we
work with students so they take the
basic Technologies we developed and
develop them further and there was a um
actually a I think it was a master
thesis about aeroponics but I don't have
we never did it by ourselves but it's
the same I think it makes sense because
it's just developing new systems mhm
it and has another system that be taking
a look as we rethink Urban agriculture
there's many different things little
pieces of the puzzle we've got to think
about depending on where we are in the
world also Mak sense for different
things yes sir here in the front row um
yep go ahead just talk he'll catch you
hey um I have a question I have at home
some little patches for growing my own
food and over the year I get like
percentage of five to for own vegetables
and
my question goes probably to you is and
I would like to know if there's a
concrete estimate for how much can we
afford when we would apply the current
best Technologies to Singapore if you
have vertical things to grow salad
whatever and rooftop farming for all
buildings if there's a like a limit we
can so the percentage that you think
could be replaced if you say you uh
import like 90% to Singapore food so
what is the best we can do with vertical
farming and all the stuff we can like
cherry trees instead of whatever uh
trees we have
now uh what is the upper bound MH of we
can do I think it's not possible to do
100% but well depends is there anything
we know good question any why don't you
go ahead cuz you look like you want to
grab that then ear I'll let then you go
I don't know if that's really the
question but we made a study within rof
water Farm about um how many food can
produce a farm on a five um on a story
five five store building and um with uh
I think 60 people live live in and the r
water from technology would um deliver
80% of fish to the people living in the
building and up to 60% of the
vegetables so it's quite a lot
and yeah so but um it's one building you
I think you have to have to think it on
a neighborhood scale but it's it's a
huge
potential yeah I don't have like
definite numbers on that actually but uh
I just know that in the current status
actually uh Technologies like vertical
farming wouldn't provide you uh with
most crops that we are using like soy in
Asia we consume so much tofu but doing
vertical farming for soy
is not very meaningful so um yeah so
currently it's mainly herbs and Ley
vegetables so then we would still need
external Supply also in terms of meat if
you still want the chicken it will be
very difficult really for highly
urbanized environments and then for the
micro algae actually uh that doesn't
relate to the work that I'm doing now
but what I was doing in my PhD I was
supporting the University of stutgart
for developing life support systems for
Mars or moon mission where they're using
microalgae to create really circular
Loops because you can also use gray
water or urine uh recycle it and grow
the micro algae on it and they actually
estimated I think with a 5 lit reactor
you could Supply a third or for the
human
needs five or to 10 liter reor which is
already a lot if you have a I don't know
8 billion people population right but
only a third because of the nutrients
also that are in the micro not one
source can
supply uh all the nutrients that you
need but I don't have a definite number
on that unfortunately that's a very
interesting thing it's very because
urine is an incredibly good
fertilizer yeah but if I would do a
survey in the group I mean you were
laughing before when Ana was mentioning
right that she's using gray water for
producing leafy vegetables for producing
burgers and then you were laughing right
so if I would ask people now how open
would you be to to eat something that
was actually grown on your
urine we did that actually really we did
that we developed with a roof water Farm
over four years a fertilizer made from
black water from the water which is
combing from the toilets yeah and we um
did measurements if it's hygienically
safe it is hygienically safe so the
products we developed were actually as
well as good good as well as the ones
you can buy in the supermarket which are
not wrapped in
plastic and all the people which were
visiting us and saw that didn't had any
problem because you could really yeah
because I was always facing that
argument because then uh something like
microalgae it if it would be safe if
there are no antibiotics other um yeah
residues from uh drugs in the water for
instance microalgae would be perfect
currently we grow them in food industry
s streams because they're technically uh
safe for usage but then we could really
do a nice Loop there if people are open
to consuming that food maybe one one
technical aspect to that um question
when you start to to um reuse the water
or to do the fertilizer decentralized
and in small amounts it's easy the water
we um which came out of our treatment
plant was much more better than the ones
from the centralized system so I think
the key is decentralization of the
Wastewater systems to reuse the water
flows like black water urine sort of
rethinking back into micro grids so many
Back to the Future right where we only
ate meat on Sundays if if at all and
then really truly lived with nature we
have time for one more question and then
there's a gentleman here in the back in
the middle he's been he hasn't quite
been dancing in his chair but he's been
trying to get that my attention for a
while so now you got it on the right
hand side yeah hi um so my question is
where're um a lot of the solutions we're
looking into um there are um technology
and uh pretty energy intensive as well
um what do you guys think about um the
tangibility of um Solutions such as food
forests and um you know going back to
traditional farming as it was before the
Agricultural
Revolution interesting
question okay so this is more like to
you if you're going Going Back to the
Future one of you Marcel what do you
think yeah I would say uh it's a super
good idea because our grand parents
teached us so much about Gathering to go
hunting to produce our own um Food local
food so I would say uh it's the best
idea um uh for the future to to produce
food next to the city in the city so I
would say uh a lot of people will have a
lot of fun to see growing the vegetables
and stuff like that so yeah I hopefully
it's the future so Ana go ahead and then
I'm going to we're going to have to
bring I just realized we're out of time
so you go ahead yeah um actually it's a
I think it's a good idea it's maybe we
are talking about technology but um it's
integrated developing Integrated
Solutions and Tiny forests and food
forests are following the same way they
they offer different possibilities for
the people living in the city and they
produce maybe
energy um or food
or places for recreation sure I'm not
envisioning a complete a future based on
technology it's practices we have to
redevelop and
redesign so with that I'd like to say
just close on a a couple things we for
me the answer to that one for many of
the things we've been asking very
directly it depends can we feed
ourselves just from our food on our
roofs it depends on how much we eat if
we eat a th000 calories a day easy right
I mean it's really it's I was just in
Mexico City a few weeks ago it's 22
million people there's no green space
anywhere you know so I'm not sure how
we're going to be able to get to Growing
your food right next to you so I'm not
quite sure here yes and in many places
that we live at this moment this is very
inspirational for me to hear also your
ideas about how we can do this and I
think we have to be very careful no one
is suggesting this is a solution for the
world this is a
contextual contextual conversation here
in Berlin is what we're thinking about
with some inspiration from Singapore
about how these systems can work
together and I think this is something
which the lessons teach us again and
again is Place matters and the context
matters the culture the environment and
so this is something I think is
important to take away as well in
addition to what you've been sharing
this has been for me an incredibly
interesting and wonderful Journey with
you um thank you all Iris Marcel and Ana
for being here with us this evening at
the eth rethinking Urban agriculture in
the in the Berlin science week so let us
thank them the normal
way and um I would really like to thank
all of you for choosing to be here on
this evening um all of us have many
things we can be doing in our lives and
you chose to come and with us rethink
something which is very dear to all of
us which is our nutrition and how we
live our lives so thank you for choosing
to be here at the Museum and also online
it's wonderful to have you with us and
for your incredibly great questions so
again thank you have a wonderful rest of
day and um eat an apple drink water be
healthy thank you thank
you there we go